president Trump meets shooting victims
and CNN runs one of the worst town halls
on gun control I have ever seen in my
life it's truly egregious orwellian two
minutes of hate stuff I'll go through
all of it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
we have a lot to get to today we're
gonna spend a lot of time with the CNN
Town Hall that took place last night
moderated by Jake Tapper I think Jake is
a pretty good journalist but I think
that this did not do him any credit I
thought that the I thought that the CNN
special last night which featured all of
these shooting survivors asking
questions of Marco Rubio really casting
accusations at Marco Rubio and it's a
lash of the National Rifle Association
and then a crowd filled with people from
Broward County where the shooting took
place cheering wildly screaming booing
it really was it was an egregious scene
I'm gonna go through all that I'm gonna
explain why it was so bad also President
Trump at the White House asking
questions of and being asked questions
by shooting survivors one of those
events was good one of those events not
so much I'll explain all of this first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so Adlon certainty in
the world right now you've seen the
volatility in the stock market's been
going up it's been going down but if you
want a safe haven if you want at least
some of your assets and precious metals
the people you need to talk to my
friends over at Birch gold so when you
go over to birchgold.com slash Bend you
get a comprehensive 16 page kit free
revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings how you can legally
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA the
nice thing about Birch gold you can
trust them they've a long-standing track
record of continued success in a plus
rating from the Better Business Bureau
countless five-star reviews there's
people I trust for my pleasure precious
metals investments go to Birch gold
group right now and ask them for the
free information kit just go to
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben use that slash
Ben as well so that they'll a they know
that we sent you there the people that I
would trust when it comes to investing
in precious metals and again everyone
should have at least part of their
portfolio in a solid asset like precious
metals alright so we begin today now at
the CNN Town Hall we'll get to that in
just a few minutes but with an actual
useful thing okay this useful thing
happened at the White House yesterday so
at the White House yesterday the
President of the United States had a
bunch of people in who had been shooting
victims family of shooting victims some
people from parkland Florida some people
from Sandy Hook some people from from
other mass shootings that have taken
place around the country and he had a
listening session with them now Trump
was mocked by the media because he was
holding a piece of paper during this
with notes on it and one of the notes
said I hear you that's the idea was oh
well I guess he's being coached to hear
people but President Trump actually is
quite good in these
sorts of situations and I think to
everyone surprised they expected him to
get angry or knee-jerk fashion argue
with folks he didn't do that he sat
there and he took it he took it on the
chin from a lot of people who are very
upset it was a wide variety of
perspectives so the media were very
upset with this because they will want
all town halls to basically be people
who are shooting victims or shooting
victims family or friends they want
those people to all be pro gun control
fanatics who go up there and yell at
politicians that's what it was on CNN
last night so they're very upset that
the White House had a variety of
perspectives said some people who are
pro-gun control some people who thought
that school safety and armed guards were
the solution but that wide variety of
perspectives was actually useful and
again it demonstrated something that the
left does not want you to believe I've
been saying this now since the Parkland
shooting I've been saying it more than
that for five years since the Piers
Morgan interview I did on CNN after the
Sandy Hook shooting the left media so
many people in the left media wish you
to believe that people who own guns
people who care about second Amendment
rights people who want to protect their
families that these are people who don't
care if children are shot but they just
don't care enough if they truly cared
enough then they'd agree with the gun
control agenda well Trump yesterday
showed that he cared and that's what
made the media so so angry about this
event I think it was a useful event I
think that it was an event that had
class I think it was an event that had
dignity and I think that it was an event
that again demonstrated that we are all
in this together this is the thing
that's missing the media are trying to
drive us apart there are a bunch of
folks on the anti-gun left who are
trying to suggest because they the only
way they can find to push their
unpopular agenda they're trying to
suggest that anyone who disagrees with
them is morally bereft that those people
have moral shortcomings the truth is
we're all neighbors we all mourn when we
see things like what happened in
parkland we all want to stop that stuff
I want the shooter to fry in hell you do
too
everyone's on the same page with this
except for the people who wish to
believe that their political opponents
are actually scum of the earth pieces of
crap who don't care about dead kids they
only care about polishing their weapons
in the background well while posing in
front of their conservative in front of
their Confederate flags but this is the
view that too many on the Left have of
law-abiding American Gunners okay so at
the White House yesterday there a bunch
of folks who spoke one of them was a
parkland father named Andrew
he was a Trump supporter there was a
famous picture of him going around
during the actual massacre he's driving
around trying to
his daughter had been murdered in the
shooting he's running Trump 2020 t-shirt
he was at the White House and here's
what he had to say to President Trump
about losing his daughter it's not about
gun laws right now that's that's another
fight another battle let's fix the
schools and then you guys can battle it
out whatever you want but we need our
children safe Munda tomorrow whatever
day it is your kids are gonna go to
school you think everyone everyone's
kids are safe I didn't think it was
gonna happen I mean if I knew it I would
have been at the school every day if I
knew it was that dangerous it's enough
let's get together work with the
president and fix the schools
okay well working with the president is
something Democrats don't want to do and
they don't want to give him credit for
moving on the issue at all even though
he tweeted out this morning that he
wants better background checks and that
he wants to ban bump stocks I think he
wants to raise the age of rifle purchase
until 21 that last measure is one that I
could understand if you're also gonna
raise the age of consents to 21 in terms
of joining the military or voting but it
seems to me that we can't grant rights
piecemeal to people we can't say you
have the right to vote but not the right
to drink or the right to bear arms it
doesn't work like that in the United
States rights are generally granted when
you reach the point of maturity or at
the point of adulthood in any case this
guy was not given this father was not
given the sort of credibility and
respect that the media normally grant to
shooting victims and fathers that they
haven't had this fellow on CNN every
single day they have had students on
every single day because obviously
there's an agenda here and the agenda is
put on young people specifically so you
can't argue with them this is the goal
here's the game the game how it's played
so a student is at a facility where
somebody is shot and the student sees
something terrible and we all grieve
with the student and so we all say we
grieve with you the students well if
you're really grieved with me you do
what I wanted and we say well you know
we can disagree on policy and still
grieve with you and then the media say
hell dare you criticize this young
person who's only showing the courage of
their convictions as I have said 1
million times at this point you can
always show the courage of your
convictions it doesn't demonstrate
necessarily the wiseness of your
convictions now I was getting a little
flak yesterday because I wrote a column
for National Review talking about how
being young does not confer evidentiary
expertise on you that being a person who
suffered doesn't come doesn't actually
confer expertise upon you as an
individual human being people say oh
yeah well you were writing columns when
17 right I was and I was being
criticized like an adult when I was 17
which is the way that it should work 17
year-olds should speak they should be
involved in politics a lot of my fans
are 17 I want them to be involved in
politics that's great but understand
when you enter the political arena your
arguments are going to be cause for for
controversy and that doesn't go away
just because you're young or just
because you went through something truly
truly awful okay that wasn't the only
Parkland survivor or family member to be
at the White House there was a wide
variety perspectives as I say there were
people there who were very critical of
Trump on guns one of them was a parkland
survivor who told Trump that he didn't
think that people should be able to buy
weapons of war I was reading today that
a person 20 years old walked into a
store and bought an ar-15 in five
minutes with an expired ID how is it
that easy to buy this type of weapon
okay that samuel was that one of the
problems here is that what he's saying
is not true I talked about this
yesterday Chris Cuomo put out a tweet
about a story that was false in which a
guy claimed that he was able to purchase
an ar-15 without showing ID and that he
was able to do so in five minutes
without a federal background check that
story was not true as we pointed out
even in the story the guy was turned
away from the gun store when he couldn't
show ID and didn't want to go through a
federal background check it shows you
the impact of the media and how their
coverage skews people's perspectives on
how easy it is to get guns it's an
enormous number of stories about how we
need a ban machine guns machine guns
have been effectively bans in the United
States since the 1980s machine guns have
to have been in very small circulation
in the United States for decades at this
point there are people who say that we
should have mental health background
checks we do have mental health
background checks in the United States
we need to make the system more
transparent we need to make the
reporting better 38 states in the United
States report less than 80 percent of
the people who shouldn't have guns to
their to their full federal background
check list but that's a problem with the
law-enforcement structure not a problem
with the the capacity of the law itself
the law itself is a lot stricter than
people think it is with regard to
purchasing weapons on the federal ever
so Trump answers all of all of these
survivors and and friends and family and
he talks about a couple of things that
he would like to do one of his proposals
is that we should arm 20% of teachers
who are actually qualified to carry
weapons in the classroom so let's say
you had 20% of your teacher
because that's pretty much the number if
these cowards knew that that was that
the school was you know well-guarded
from the standpoint of having pretty
much professionals with great training
I think they wouldn't go into the school
to start off with I think it could very
well solve your problem okay so a lot of
people are very upset about this how
dare he say that he was going to arm
twenty percent of teachers now but the
media did is they lied they said that he
wanted to harm all teachers he did not
say he wanted to harm all teachers he
said if you're qualified he was
specifically it turns out signaling is
singling out mx vets military members
police I'm not sure it's the best
solution I think armed security guards
are a better solution in uniform on
campus you know deterring people from
committing crimes but the media lied
about what he said and then blew it up
to epic proportions in just a second
we'll talk about the impact of what
Trump did and then we will get to what
was just an egregious media display of
bias there was a lot of immorality going
on last night on CNN again this is not
to say that victims should not be able
to speak out they should speak out it's
not to say that victims should not be on
TV that's fine with me if they're on TV
what it is to say is that this CNN other
outlets like CNN only have big town
halls in liberal areas with shooting
victims they would never have for
example a full Town Hall with it case in
point they would never have a full Town
Hall with people who are victims of
illegal immigrant crime in Phoenix
Arizona Sean Hannity might but you never
see that on CNN on their quote-unquote
objective news shows but Sean isn't is
not an objective reporter he says that
openly but CNN claims to be objective
and therein lies the problem so before I
get to any of that first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at blue
apron blue apron is the leading meal kit
delivery service in the United States
and they are the number one fresh
ingredient recipe delivery service they
make incredible home cooking accessible
to everyone people in our office people
outside our office everybody loves blue
apron the way that it works is that you
go online you register with their
service and they will send you recipes
and the pre-portioned ingredients and
you cook it there in your home they have
three plans a two person meal plan that
serves two people you can choose from
eight new recipes for week with the
choice to receive either two or three
recipes in any week they have a family
meal plan they have a wine plan all of
this is just fantastic its convenience
and it is variety they deliver fresh
pre-portion ingredients step-by-step
recipes right to your door
these things can be
cooked in under 45 minutes in the menu
changes every week so you never gonna
have to get bored with spaghetti night
again for the ninth time on a Tuesday in
a row they also offer 12 new recipes
each week customers can pick two three
or four recipes based on what fist fits
their schedule the best and again they
send only non GMO ingredients in meat
with no added hormones there's nothing
more fun than cooking with your kids I
do it with my kids all the time and you
will love doing it with blue apron and
right now they're treating my listeners
230 bucks off your first order pretty
good deal if you visit blue apron comm
slash Shapiro that's blue apron comm
slash Shapiro use that slash prepare to
get that 30 bucks off at blue apron comm
and again that lets them know that we
sent you it is a fantastic service and
listen to some of these things I mean
strip steaks with potatoes and spicy
maple collard greens it's it's its
Steakhouse inspired favorites it's spicy
chicken and stir fried vegetables with
jasmine rice it's creamy fusilli bukata
pasta you know what that is but it looks
great I'm looking at a picture of it
with fried rosemary and walnuts you're
cooking like a professional you're
cooking like gourmet with blue apron
blue apron calm slash if you're the
family the cooks together stays together
and the food's better blue apron calm
slash apparel get 30 bucks off your
order at blue apron calm slash apparel
okay so last night I get home from my
long day in Washington DC and I flip on
CNN because everybody on Twitter is
talking about this townhall now I knew
that this Town Hall was going to go
wildly wrong from the start because CNN
has an agenda here and I know they were
claiming that it's just students who are
asking questions but people would CNN
are journalists they know what a loaded
question sounds like right a loaded
question is when did you stop beating
your wife senator that's a loaded
question that was the entirety of the
Town Hall last night so the people who
are there it was the it was senators
from Florida so Senator Marco Rubio and
the Democratic senator from Florida
who's whose name is bill bill Nelson say
he's been the senator there since 2001
they were both there Dana lash from the
NRA showed up as well and this turned
into basically a hootenanny it was it
was a bunch of people in the crowd the
hundreds of people in the crowd from the
Broward County are and the number one
important to note Broward County
Democratic area very left area voted for
Hillary Clinton in a state that went red
for Donald Trump they voted I think it
was 54 to 46 for Hillary
in that area and this area of Broward
counties apparently pretty left the the
sheriff there died named Steve Israel
has been photographed with Bernie
Sanders and Hillary Clinton so it's a
Democrat area so the shooting took place
in a Democrat area and the people there
were family and friends of victims so
what you are likely to get when you set
this up is obviously emotions running
incredibly high and also an agenda that
is obviously very clear and this thing
turned into a debacle right from the
start with people asking questions that
were utterly inappropriate on a moral
level hey just because you've suffered
something doesn't mean you get to say
immoral things there were kids there who
are saying some of the most immoral
things that truly immoral things so for
example let's do clip 28 so this is
Cameron caskey he's one of the students
who's been most featured on CNN because
obviously they're not gonna feature a
bunch of students who are right-wing
that wouldn't be a thing instead they're
going to feature students who are
left-wing so Cameron Caskey asks asks
Rubio a question and in the process of
the question he makes he says something
that is so deeply immoral it's shocking
and it should be gut turning to you
senator Rubio it's hard to look at you
and not look down the barrel of an ar-15
and not look at Nicolas Cruz but the
point is you're here and there are some
people who are not okay that right there
it's hard not to look at you and be
looking down the barrel of the shooters
gun I understand you just went through
something I understand what you went
through was difficult and terrible and
horrible and no person should have to go
through that I get all of that that
statement is deeply immoral that is a
disgusting statement Marco Rubio didn't
shoot anybody Marco Rubio did not walk
into a school and mow down children and
Marco Rubio's agenda is not to
facilitate the mowing down of children
but again the left suggestion here is
that everyone who is not on their side
must be acting in bad faith
the only people acting in bad faith who
sit are the people who say stuff like
that those are the only people who are
acting in bad faith I mean the entire
night was just an evening of
grandstanding my political officials and
an evening of throwing around the most
immoral morally charged language by some
of the students and listen your
obligation to be a moral human being and
say moral things does not stop when you
experience tragedy to suggest that Marco
Rubio is akin to a school shooter is
disgusting it's disgusting and I I'm not
saying that the kid is
disgusting I'm saying that statement is
disgusting because the statement is
disgusting and again bad statements
immoral statements they don't become
less immoral just because you experience
some pain and I know that people on the
Left agree with me because if there was
a bombing victim or a family of a
bombing victim or a witness to a bombing
who said let's throw every Muslim in the
United States out of the country the
left would say that's an immoral
statement and they'd be right that is an
immoral statement it is an immoral
statement to also say that a sitting
senator in the United States wants
children to die once children to die
simply so they can get whatever it is
nine thousand dollars that Rubio got
from the National Rifle Association okay
that CNN special last night was designed
to do one thing and that was to drive a
moral wedge between fellow Americans
truly truly despicable okay that was not
the limit of it of course the Broward
County Sheriff Steve Israel was there as
well and he was there in his full-scale
Democratic capacity so let's do a quick
flashback this sheriff whose department
missed 39 separate warnings on this kid
okay the the shooter the department was
visiting this shooters home six to seven
times a year for years and they still
didn't have enough authority supposedly
to put this kid away to get the to take
guns away from from this person I mean
the Sheriff's Office missed it they blew
it but what is the sheriff blaming it on
well of course he's gonna blame it on
gun so here's a flashback here's Steve
Israel this is just last week standing
with Rick Scott the governor of the
state of Florida and pushing gun control
in fur Brett Scott right so that guy
right there is obviously a political
actor with a political agenda but he was
portrayed on CNN as just a sheriff right
just a law enforcement official okay the
guy's a Democrat obviously and he has an
agenda pretty obviously no where was
that clearer than when Dana lash over at
the NRA who was there asked the sheriff
okay so why didn't you stop it right
you're the law enforcement body you were
warned what did you do about it and the
media's response to Dana was how dare
Dana lash asks he hit Steve Israel
something it's one thing to blame Marco
Rubio for the shooting it's another to
blame the actual sheriff who's
responsible for maintaining the safety
and security of the students of Broward
County it's another
he blew it you know it's one thing to
blame gun owners like me all the way
across the country in Los Angeles but to
blame you know to cast any weary eye
upon the the sheriff who's responsible
for security
how dare Dana lash this clip 31 just
again listen look at the crowds response
to to Dana asking you a very solid
question here we need the power to take
every firearm they have away from them
and bring them to a mental health
facility assaulting students assaulting
parents taking bullets and knives to
school did that not meet that standard
well which which which he is speaking
about specifically you seem to know
about all 39 well there's I know there's
one Florida Statute where if he's
sending messages if he's sending
messages threatening to kill people that
right there under Florida State law did
he send the message to kill people to
buzzfeed ap Reuters can't be a victim
the only person who could be a victim is
individuals individual was threatened
and it was real that's a crime yes they
were threatened with death they were
threatened that they were going to bleed
they were threatened that they were
going to be killed well what's your
specifically and he had already taken
bullets and knives to school he had
already assaulted people he assaulted
his parent he assaulted other students
39 visits okay and of course the crowd
starts turning on Dana for mentioning
the fact that when you visit a home
thirty-nine times and the AYGO shoots up
a school maybe you missed something
right how many red flags do you have to
have okay that seems like a better
question to me than Marco Rubio you're
obviously Satan what are you doing here
why are you why are you Satan
why are you Satan and all of this of
course was forwarded and and nodded on
by CNN I mean listen to Emma Gonzales
Emma Gonzales is another one of the
students who's been featured on CNN a
lot you can always tell which were the
students are pro-gun control because
those are the ones whose faces you
actually recognize so when you look at
Emma can tell us you'll recognize her
face because you saw it on CNN a lot
when you see some of the other students
who were not at the CNN Town Hall for
reasons that we will discuss in a second
then what you will see is that you don't
recognize their faces because they're
not on CNN Eliza here's Emma Gonzales
who actually says straight out to Dana
lash that she's gonna support Dana
lashes kids better than then Dana lashes
Dana Loesch I want you to know that we
will support your two children in the
way that we will not you will not the
shooter at our school obtained weapons
that he used on us legally do you
believe that it should be harder to
obtain the semi-automatic and a lot of
weapons and the modifications for these
weapons to make them fully automatic
like bump stocks
well first off Emma I want to applaud
you for standing up and speaking out and
for anyone who has ever criticized you
or any of these students up here
including people who have been on my
side of this issue okay so good for Dana
for not taking the bait there but again
what a horrifying statement I'm gonna
defend your children away you won't I'd
like to see Emma Gonzales named Dana
lashes kids she doesn't know Dana's kids
again the implication is that Dana must
not care about children because Dana
doesn't agree with Emma Gonzales on this
issue it got worse than that an audience
member actually called Dana lash a
murderer in the middle of the special
nobody says a word it's just incredible
this is a clip 24 do you know that it is
not federally required for states to
actually report people who are
prohibited possessors crazy people
people who are murderers no we've been
actually talking about that for a long
time let me answer the question let me
answer the question you can shout me
down when I'm finished but let me answer
in this question okay and you can
actually hear in the background audience
members shouting at Dana that she's a
murderer if you believe that Marco Rubio
is the murderer
if you live with Dana lash as the
murderer but if you don't believe that
the shooter is responsible for his own
actions and if you believe that 300
million people in the United States have
to have their gun rights removed from
them instead of us focusing on how to
fix this issue if you think we're all
that unsympathetic then I would suggest
you have a screw loose you actually do
have a problem your morality is skewed
beyond belief if you think Dana lashes
murderer or Marco Rubio is equivalent to
the man who shot children in the face at
a parkland high school just repulsive it
got even worse than that well that
wasn't even the extent of it so we will
we'll discuss the rest of that
in just one second so let's let's start
with some of the questions that were
asked of senator Rubio so senator Rubio
again he is not the best advocate for
the Second Amendment he's the senator
from Florida which is why he was there
but senator Rubio has a bad habit of
trying to please the crowd that is in
front of him and so during the course of
this debate he kind of moved on a bunch
of issues regarding raising the age of
buying weapons as well as the the
availability of ar-15s and and all the
rest of us the the questions that were
being asked were truly were truly
amazing so this is clip 12 you're going
to see the the father of one of the of
the murdered students trying to push
Rubio to say that guns had were the sole
reason for the shooting and Rubio won't
go there and the crowd starts booing him
which again demonstrates the silliness
of this it is true by the way that guns
were a factor here because the gun was
used just as in any murder the murder
weapon is a factor but does that mean it
is the sole factor of course not that's
ridiculous you and I are now eye-to-eye
because I want to like you look at me
and tell me guns
were the factor in the hunting of our
kids in this school this week and look
at me and tell me you accept it and you
will work with us to do something about
guns okay and then Rubio answers by
saying of course guns were a factor but
they were not the deciding factor which
of course is true that of course is true
and there's a fantastic thread on
Twitter that that an actual scholar has
written about about what exactly it is
that that mass shooters have in common
and bottom line is it is a large variety
of factors it is not one thing it as
many things but we don't we can't handle
that in the United States so it always
has to come down to one thing
and of course Marco Rubio has to be
browbeaten for for being a Second
Amendment
advocate it gets even worse than that
okay so watch this this is this is the
clip that is going to be played over and
over and over by Second Amendment
advocates you understand if you are a if
you are an advocate for gun control the
worst thing you can do right now in a
time when everyone is on the same side
regarding the horrors that just happened
the worst thing you can do is claim that
those of us who disagree with you are
evil and nasty you're seeing movement
you are I mean just bit of political
advice yours
seeing movement from people on the
pro-gun side saying we'd be willing to
look at certain gun control measures we
may not have been willing to look at
before I may not agree with that policy
decision on their part but that is what
is happening in real time instead of you
embracing that instead of you saying you
obviously want to come to the table
let's see if there are places where we
can agree instead of us all coming to
the table on issues that may not have to
do with confiscating weaponry but
instead may have to do with securing
schools on those issues instead of you
doing that you are you aren't overtly
alienating people who disagree with you
so here is an example of this so this is
clip 30 so Rubio is talking about how
the well you know before he it's clip 30
clip 29 bill Nelson is the Democratic
senator and Bill Nelson mentions the
very beginning how he wants to ban what
he calls assault weapons including the
ar-15 assault weapons again has no legal
definition any rifle could theoretically
be an assault weapon depending on the
magazine size or the color or the grip
or the shape or whether there's a sight
on it or any of the rest of us so when
bill nelson mentions banning the ar-15
of course there's big applause because
again this is a stacked town hall
instead of solutions like getting the
assault rifles off the streets
[Applause]
I will point out that when the Democrats
brought up an assault weapons ban in
2009 only 38 Democrats voted in favor of
it the the entire Senate voted it down
overwhelmingly so Marco Rubio later he
says listen that all sounds well and
good right getting assault weapons off
the streets and all of us you're talking
about banning every semi-automatic gun
in the United States effectively
speaking and listen to the crowd start
looking at how easy it is to get around
it you would literally have a ban every
semi-automatic rifle
fair enough okay and here's the point
right if you want to ban all
semi-automatic rifles when he says you
have to ban all semi-automatic rifles
for people who don't know what a
semi-automatic rifle is a semi-automatic
weapon is just a weapon where when you
pull the trigger one's one shot comes
out and another round is chambered that
is all a semi-automatic weapon is it's
basically everything except for like a
single action revolver right that's it
that or a double action revolver rather
it's it's it's pretty much any gun in
the United States is effectively a
semi-automatic weapon right old six
shooters are basically semi-automatic
weapons okay at least they function like
semi-automatic weapons in the sense that
one trigger pole means one bullet is
fired and they're talking now about full
gun bans right which would also I assume
have to include full gun confiscation
right they'd also have to be talking
about taking away all of the guns
because it's not enough to ban people
from buying new guns there are too many
guns already out there now you can get a
hold of a gun if you just go to a
private seller it's not that hard so you
have to create a registry and then you'd
have to ban people from selling and then
you'd probably have to confiscate the
weapons because you don't want them out
there anyway because how many people
already own guns now there are 300
million guns in the United States 300
million guns in the United States and a
hundred million gun owners what in the
world are you talking about
I encourage Democrats to go down this
path you know this this is a campaign ad
for the NRA okay that last clip was a
campaign ad for the end right now the
media last night we're going wild over
this
look how Rubio stepped right into that
one you made a proposal and the
Democrats cheered it all right go for it
do it do it I want to see you propose
the full repeal of the Second Amendment
to the United States Constitution
you need 38 states to do it you're gonna
be lucky if you reach 15 are you out of
your minds but apparently the answer is
yes because look the reality is there is
no solution that is dependent on getting
rid of the Second Amendment it's not
going to happen it's not a reality you
try going down to Texas and confiscating
all those weapons you see how that goes
you won't see a lot of dead people
that's the way you see a lot of dead
people is mass confiscations of weaponry
in the United States not going to happen
but again the media are so beside
themselves they feel like their agenda
is finally being forwarded what they
don't understand is the only thing that
changed today from last night because of
the CNN special is a bunch of
Republicans went out and bought an ar-15
last night I was browsing rifles online
I was in browsing rifles because I'm
interested in more violence I'm browsing
rifles because I
the Democrats are gonna move to try and
make it illegal for me to own one and I
if I want to protect my family then I
want the gun of my choice to protect my
family because guess what I'm not gonna
mow down children and I want to be able
to stop the bad guy who does want to mow
down children Democrats are shooting
themselves right in the foot with this
sort of stuff and worse they're dividing
the country and that's really what this
is about they're really about trying to
get people out to the polls trying to
use this as a wedge issue they think
they can get people really excited I
promise you all of the anti-gun
advocates who aren't so deeply excited
about going to the polls there are a lot
more Americans who own guns know people
who own guns have fired a gun than
people in the United States who have not
now I listen I know I'm from Los Angeles
nobody in Los Angeles owns a gun right
gun ownership in Los Angeles is very
well people in New York not a lot of gun
ownership in New York but get out of the
media centers of LA and in New York get
into the middle of the country and
everybody owns multiple guns you're
talking about a culture war that the
left has entered into in an area where
it was unnecessary and directly
polarizing for no reason and the media
are boosting this because the media have
an agenda and that agenda is to
castigate everybody who they disagree
with is deplorable this is just another
version of Hillary Clinton stick about
how everybody on the other side is a
deplorable who's a bad human being I
hate this more than a more than anything
in politics is the demonization of
people who have just basic political
disagreements with you as morally evil
actors and yet that is what they are
doing day after day after day it's
really gross they did it again to Rubio
last night a student hammered Marco
Rubio in taking NRA donations now let's
point something out okay again this is
one of these leftist Bugaboos they do
this with regard to Charles Koch for
example they say if you take NRA money
this makes you an NRA show well in just
a second I'm going to show you how Marco
Rubio answers that charge but making the
NRA into the enemy is of course one of
the chief goals that left so we're going
to talk about that in just a second
plus it an egregious column by EJ Dionne
over at the Washington Post which we
will get to and some things I like and
things I hate but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire calm and
subscribed for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to Daley we're calm see
the rest of my show live see the rest of
Andrew Klavan show live see the rest of
Michael nolza show live be part of the
mailbag which we will be doing tomorrow
you got all of those wonders when you
subscribe plus you get the leftist tears
hot or cold tumblr when you get the
annual subscription for $99 a year it's
cheaper than
monthly subscription you want to listen
for free later all you have to do is go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud or Google
Play or stitcher or YouTube subscribe to
our channel over at YouTube please leave
us a review it always helps we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so as I say the the attempt to paint the
NRA as the enemy is truly an astonishing
one the left has been trying to do this
for years the NRA is gay I mean I think
the NRA is making a mistake the end of
the midstate the NRA is making win
Lapierre who's the head of the NRA did a
speech today at CPAC where I'll be
speaking a little bit later and in that
speech he talked about he really went
hard against the Democratic Party he
really said some polarizing things about
the nature of the political divide I
don't think that's useful the whole
point of gun ownership in the United
States that does cross party lines right
now approval ratings for the NRA about
80 percent for Republican only nine
percent for Democrats just a few years
ago 36 percent of Democrats approved of
the NRA now would it help if the NRA
were a little bit less overtly partisan
sure would it also help if the Democrats
weren't trying to use the NRA as a club
to beat all of their enemies into
submission that would probably help to
well as an example of this one of these
students gets up and starts hammering
Rubio on taking NRA donations and Rubio
won't commit to now take me on I read
donations because why the hell should he
the NRA is a legal body he's taken away
nine thousand dollars in the last
election cycle I can relative nothing
but they're asking him to disassociate
from a fully legal Second Amendment
pushing organization of law-abiding
Americans six million strong and he
refuses to do it but this of course
makes him a villain because it's the NRA
responsible for the shootings not the
sheriff who blew it not the FBI that
blew it not the shooter not the school
the people responsible for all of this
are of course people who have nothing to
do with it far away who own guns and
have an NRA membership card here's the
student hammering Rubio on NRA donations
clip 22 senator Rubio can you tell me
right now that you will not accept a
single donation from the NRA
so number one the positions I hold on
these issues of the Second Amendment
I've held since the day I entered office
in the city of West Miami as an elected
official number two no the answer is the
question is that people buy into my
agenda and I do support the Second
Amendment and I also support the right
of you and everyone here to be able to
go to school and be safe and I do
support any law that would keep guns out
of the hands of a deranged killer and
that's why I support the things that I
have stood for in there that is the
wrong way to look first of all the
answer is people buy into my agenda
you give second well I say aye
the influences I think we're gonna be
here all night the influence of these
groups comes not from money the
influence comes from the millions of
people that agree with the agenda
millions American to support the NRA and
in the name of 17 people you cannot ask
the NRA to keep their money out of your
campaign I think in the name of 17
people I can pledge to you that I will
support any law that will prevent a
killer like this no but I'm talking
money okay I mean look at this look at
this disgusting display okay again this
is the the leading questions that like
in tappers just sitting there I like
Jake but Jake is just sitting there and
he's allowing this kid to browbeat the
senator with a bunch of loaded questions
that have nothing then he's not even
moving to try and quiet the crowds that
Rubio can answer the questions if you're
gonna let the kid just go off like this
which is fine you wanna do that that's
fine Rubio put himself there at least
tell the crowd to shut up okay at a
presidential debates they tell the crowd
to shut up all the time why is this any
different hey why is it different I
understand there are a lot of people in
there who suffered a lot of people who
are upset but if you don't want it to
turn into devolve into the Orwellian two
minutes of hate then this is not the way
to do it it's not the way to do it I
mean Rubio can't even answer the
question because people are too busy
yelling at him there's another lady who
got up later and tried to lecture Rubio
on the Second Amendment she completely
botched the history of the Second
Amendment didn't understand what it was
about and it was cheered by members of
the media again this is designed for
only one thing and that is to polarize a
debate that requires no polarization and
the people who are being disrespected in
this debate are not the students there
are some morons out there who are
disrespecting the students and
suggesting that the students are paid
lackeys
but that's disrespectful so when you
suggest that Rubio is I paid Lackey of
the NRA aren't you suggesting the same
thing a little common baseline respect
to go a long way here I respect the
right of these students to ask the
questions I don't know if the questions
are well informed I don't think they are
I don't think the quote the questions
are all even moral but they have the
right to ask the questions I support the
right of the students to speak up
doesn't make what they're saying any
smarter I think that's everybody's right
in the United States but if there's one
side of this debate that's not being
respected it's it isn't that isn't
people like me I think that the people
on the other side care about Ted kids I
think that the people who are for gun
control do cry do we salt do do we real
tears
real tears over the deaths of children I
think that they are not bad people
they're my fellow Americans I think that
there are good people who want to stop
bad things from happening you got to
give me the same credit got him giving
me the same benefit of the doubt or
you're a bad person because you have no
evidence whatsoever that I don't care
about kids I cared about kids before I
had them I have two now I care about
kids even more the notion that I'm
sitting around happy when kids die
because the NRA just sold some more guns
or some such garbage that's exactly what
it is it is garbage
so EJ Dionne has an egregiously bad
column over at the Washington Post today
in which he suggests that the people who
are who are not receiving respect are
the folks who are in favor of gun
control
he says supporters of even modest
restrictions on firearms are regularly
instructed that their ardent add because
he turns off Americans in rural areas
and small towns those in favor of
reforming our firearms laws are scolded
as horrific elitist who disrespected
valued way of life well no that's not
what happens people who claim that I
don't care about dead kids those are the
people who I scorn he says as the mass
killings continue we are urged to be
patient and to spend our time listening
earnestly to the views of those who see
even a smidgen of actions limit access
to guns as the first step toward
confiscation well the reason people
think it's the first step toward
confiscation is when you have large
crowds of people openly cheering gun
confiscation that would probably be it
he says our task is not to fight for
laws to protect innocence but to
demonstrate that we really honestly
truly cross our hearts positively love
gun owners and wouldn't for an instant
think anything ill of them what is odd
is that those with extreme pro-gun views
those pushing for new laws to allow
people to carry just about anytime
anywhere I never called upon to model
similar empathy toward children killed
the mourning parents left behind people
in urban neighborhoods suffering from
violence or the majority of Americans
who don't own guns are is that are you
insane are you insane Ethan glass two
weeks have been the last two weeks have
been this okay the last two weeks have
been everybody on the right being told
to sit down and shut up because people
who are survivors are speaking now all
rights been identity politics of
suffering we've been told that we have
to treat every not not just the people
which we should treat with respect but
that we ought to treat everything that
comes out of their mouths with an
unparalleled level of respect now the
great irony in all of this of course is
that if there are survivors who are not
pro-gun control those people have
essentially been marginalized now one of
the students is claiming that he was
invited to the CNN
debate but then was not allowed to ask a
question because he was basically being
fed questions by the CNN by the CNN
folks which is a pretty astounding
accusation I expected to be able to ask
my questions and give my opinion on my
questions but Colton hobb a member of
the Junior ROTC who's shielded
classmates in the midst of Terror says
he did not get to share his experience
CNN had originally asked me to write a
speech and questions and it ended up
being all scripted Colton wrote
questions about school safety suggested
using veterans as armed school security
guards but claims CNN wanted him to ask
a scripted question instead so he
decided not to go I don't think that
it's gonna get anything accomplished
it's not gonna ask the true questions
that all the parents and teachers and
students have so CNN denied that this
happened they said we would never we
would never leak questions at a town
hall you did last time when Donna
Brazile who was then working for the CNN
and ended up running the DNC leaked
questions from the CNN Town Hall to
Hillary Clinton so yeah you've done that
before and then they say we would never
script anything we would never script
anything now I don't know if CNN tried
to script the students question my guess
is that this the CNN may have said to
him we want you to write down your
question on a piece of paper so that we
can sort of contain it but apparently
what they said is he wrote sort of a
little speech instead of a question
well did you watch any of the clips that
we just played did you watch any of
those clips the students were giving
little speeches okay Cameron kasky was
being given minutes at a time to just go
after Rubio over and over and over and
over having one student who thought
differently would that have been the
world's most terrible thing would that
have been just the worst thing in the
world and as Michelle Malkin points out
CNN has done this before
right they've actually planted people in
debates before to ask specific questions
so at a democratic debate in Vegas in
2007 Wolf Blitzer introduced several
citizen questioners quote ordinary
people and undecided voters they later
turned out to include a former Arkansas
Democratic director of political affairs
the president of the Islamic Society of
Nevada and a far left anti-war activist
who've been quoted in newspapers
lambaste and Harry Reid for his failure
to pull out of Rock so the media have
done this sort of thing before do I know
that that's what happened here no I'm
not suggesting that anybody was paid to
be there what I am suggesting is it was
a self-selected crowd of people if you
are
right wing second Amendment supporter
you did not go to that Town Hall last
night because you knew it was run by CNN
because you know CNN is out to sandbag
gun gun supporters and because you know
that your view is going to be a typical
and you won't get to ask a question I
mean this thing was was about as rigged
from the start as it possibly could be
and people there knew it
okay people there knew it suffice it to
say I know people at CNN who are
involved in making this and who
acknowledged freely that this thing was
rigged for emotion and was rigged for
left-wing views in Broward County and it
was a bunch of shooting victims who have
already been on CNN specifically talking
about why they want gun control and this
this sort of again it is painful to me I
mean I had trouble sleeping last night
after watching this not because I think
that in all good conscience had to
support gun control but because I think
that we cannot last as a country we
cannot last as a country if we are going
to continue to maintain that people who
disagree with us are inherently bad
human beings this cannot stand is the
one issue where we all agree the one
issue in all of life where we agree is
this issue right it's the issue don't
let kids die this is the one issue where
we're on the same page and yet there's
this hardcore drive to to deploy to
deploy falsehood about even that even
that we can't even agree on that now
okay and you can see the the bad faith
of the media and MSNBC host for example
yesterday and went after Governor Rick
Scott of Florida because Governor Rick
Scott wasn't in his office a bunch of
students showed up and they wanted to
talk with him and and here's what this
MSNBC host had to say the governor is
too busy
to meet with them today and as you can
see they have they have file boxes of
paperwork that they want the government
to see they're gonna try and drop it off
at which tag here the bills here the
bills
they're saying shame on you they're
chanting that over and over again
there's only one problem here we can
stop this this dolt for a second okay
that is a why he had not turned them
away from his door he was at the funeral
of a shooting victim and the media
covered this is the rick Scott was
barring his door to a bunch of
sympathetic survivors that's not what
happened
none matter the media have to portrayed
as the Republicans or uncaring Nazis who
don't who don't shed tears over children
who are murdered this sort of media
biases is truly is truly gross and NBC
News is doing the same thing again if
the media want us to actual actually
find solutions I have a couple of
solutions I've been suggesting over the
last several days including we can call
on the media who apparently love their
ratings to stop showing the faces and
names of mass shooters they won't do
that because it might have to sacrifice
some ratings and ad dollars if they do
that so instead they'll keep putting
those people on TV even though studies
say that the more you show these folks
on TV the more you're making it likely
that the next mass shooter goes out and
does mass shooting the matter the onus
is on gun owners who have nothing to do
with any of this just incredible okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things I like
today so a movie that was not nominated
for Best Picture but it should have been
it maybe I think it's one of the best
films of the year pretty pretty easily
it probably in my top four and I would
say top floor films that I've seen this
year Blade Runner 2049 the Dunkirk the
darkest hour and and the Florida Project
the Florida project just came out and it
is oh it's it's been out for a little
while it's nominated I think Willem
Dafoe is probably gonna win Best
Supporting Actor this year for Florida
project it is a very good May so hard to
watch movies not one that you're gonna
want to buy and watch over and over but
it is really an important I'd really say
it's an important move but this is
actually I think an important movie the
movies the Florida project here's a
little bit of the preview
okay I warned it one trip in your house
its mountain inside okay so that the
entire movie is about this little girl
who is living in basically a rundown
motel Willem Dafoe is the manager of the
motel and her mom is a drug addict who
later turns to prostitution to make ends
meet and really in her mouth that the
whole thing is about intergenerational
cycles of poverty why they continue how
children are trained not to behave are
trained not to how childhood wonder
tries to flourish even in bad situations
and how children love their parents even
when their parents are disaster areas
but the movie is is moving and I think
says a lot about how poverty does not
necessary often does not create values
values very often creates poverty I may
not be the message they were trying to
push with a movie that's then that's the
message the movie ends up the movie ends
up pushing anyway okay time for a couple
of things that I hate so let's jump
right in okay so the first thing that I
hate obviously look I've talked about
disrespect toward people who are second
Amendment advocates one of these
stupidest grossest things that I've seen
over the last couple of days are these
people who are claiming that parkland
students are crisis actors or paid
advocates for a particular political
position it's just yucky it's just gross
and if you're doing this here's
disgusting there's a parkland student
who came out and said who actually had
to come out on national TV and say I'm
not a crisis actor well of course you're
not but when you show this these people
saying this is absolutely disturbing and
I'm not an actor in any sense way shape
or form I'm the son of a former FBI
agent and that is true but as such it is
also true that I went to that I go to
some in Douglas high school and I was a
witness to this I'm not a crisis actor
I'm somebody that had to witness this
and live through this and I continue to
have to do that but I'm also that it's
just it's unbelievable to me that these
people are even saying this and the fact
that Donald Trump jr. like
that post is disgusting to me but it's
also false okay so I agree with pretty
much everything this kid just said I
disagree with him on everything having
to with gun control again give the kid
the credit to say that he has his own
viewpoint even if his viewpoint is wrong
and don't pretend that this stuff is
conspiratorial crisis acting it's just
sheer nonsense okay we are out of time
because I have to get ready to go
through my speech at CPAC we'll recap
that tomorrow you can probably watch the
speech online at CPAC which is strewing
so go check that out I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben
Shapiro show is produced by Mathis
Glover executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018